heiko hubertz is
what you might call an entrepreneur
pig in the best sense of the word someone who
recognizes entrepreneurial opportunities and follows them
immediately and he was the
first to discover the topic of gaming with the spirit in
the end it went on
for him gaming then went all the way to
about the playboy mansion and deals with
ralph dommermuth you can find everything about it
here in the video whereby the video is
only an audio track because when
heiko was our guest our
cameraman was ill nevertheless content worth listening to
on youtube
let's go heiko hubertz
hello you want to be from the north but
only then did the
water in berlin home in heath or where
were you like today i was born
but to be honest it's in the
village there you can't tear anything so it was
clear very quickly that  i moved to hamburg
and then started my first
activities
as a student or in the
FH wedel h  but since I
studied computer science for a couple of semesters, ten of the
best ones dropped out because it wasn’t
so liberalization of the
telecommunications market and I got
a good job offer
I thought the money had to come
quickly and then I could
continue studying that was the money  then good
but much more but understood after
a good year so if that's the free
economy that he can do it on his
own
so quit and didn't go back to
study but have now
founded a company yes that was back then
without a so-called audio text
platform we have a wide
range of service offers for telecommunications companies at that time
so that they can make
audio applications that was the way
it was you can only say that the ringtone used to be
since that was exactly what happened then i
got to know the ringtone
very quickly back then the so-called
990 numbers which were even so famous
for  certain service but that's
ma  n also sell logos and ringtones
so long before the parents would
know it was chaos at the time
we were out there and ringtones
also a funny story somehow made a
lot of money back then i
remember exactly that we were in the
bild newspaper nationwide for  50,000 euros an
advert switched off where now a logo became
a ringtone for your mobile phone
and then we turned it into a quarter of a
million highly profitable
also a nice anecdote that's when I
first came into contact with oliver
sommer had just founded jammer then
wrote me an e-  mail what
you are doing if I just
meet you exciting but I just thought who
is that wants that from me and had
never answered
that means it should that looks quite
good and then this ringtone
time is at some point not over at all
more yes times was then at some point so
to speak completely over yes exactly that
was over then but have other
services  makes a lot of digital
services the company was able to
sell it at a reasonable price that was
the whole new economy period late 90s
early 2008 then in 2002
able to sell my share for a prominent
amount that was enough
to move back to hamburg i have to that
lived in düsseldorf at the time then moved
back to hamburg
bought it today and it does something different
my company back then had 70 employees
and i thought such a big company
would never do it again yes well me 70
meters is amazing what the
effort it was  after hamburg uster 14
programmers had the idea of
a computer game when you got a frien
together and devel
ped a computer game a footb
ll game yeah and that's reall
good and it kind of turned into a big
company there
was also counting rang
a lot of criticism i mean that people say
okay you were on the side of those d  ie
subscriptions also ended fairly and
then let them expire i would
like to say between the subscriptions yes
so that we said to each other this way
i could lose weight on my stomach and on the whole
market blah blah
the big topic for us was that we
said  okay you pay us
practice for 10 to 15 euros for logo and
ringtone today just
paid wisely so you don't mind the price but it was
completely okay for the people that was
never the case today and the work was much
longer and much more effective that's
why I was able to do better marketing
Purchasing we could have done that back then
before I went to the market
and
we just didn't have it easy
more precisely is probably afterwards
but it's not either I think
in the area it's fair and yet
somehow socially certainly you can
sleep more peacefully and committed now
losing aggressiveness is
not a defeat either,
but then it started again so you
have  then discovered gaming yes but more
by chance so really this
big company didn’t want to have it anymore and said
then we could do something like that a football
manager that was like that the the actual
idea you have to say that i had
sold yours then
we moved again and we  both my buddy
didn't
bother to make our football manager because both
football fans are gladbach fans i
just buy a house and then try it
against each other a bit
we developed it
i couldn't stop programming myself
and studied computer science
and then he just programmed it and
put it live noticed that it was
boring just the two of us against each other
so we sent
out a few emails invited a few buddies
hey play with us too
mildly we quickly invited other people again
if you were strong the server
nas server  servers were somehow still rented very cheaply via strato at that time
and with clear so ok
while there are two options either
we throw everyone out and
only a very specific number of users
are allowed to play here which was a hobby project at the
beginning or we find a
business model that was very clear
advertising that was like 2002/2003
years  so the internet market actually
couldn't pay good money
for advertising anymore what
people pay for then we came up with a country
that does it like real
football pictures and let the
users sell real better football players
then they could stop with us
the top striker the top goalkeeper
the top trainer the top masseur for a period
of 50 cents or euros each and
suddenly and we thought about 12 of
these players buys then the
servers were maybe because I could
still buy a few euros with it but of course I do it
play they don't buy one
or two top players they
buy at least eleven plus another for
the bank dami  t can exchange them
and now
we have earned real money and we even made only
20,000 euros with it so small
money underlined 120000
euros a month but only cost me strato server of 150 euros
yes so gail says it can be up to
it and my buddy  he's more soy
the banker type yes worked at the german
bank even said the company said
i don't want to make anything big out of it
and i really wanted to
do more otherwise well or the
long pass i'll give you the
soccer game that you can have on your own
everything we have  Then of course
I won’t have anything to do, but I want you to give me
the ok to set up
something big myself, and
I agreed to that. Then I
founded bigpoint, which later grew to
more than 1000 good people and a
few hundred million  players had
but it shouldn't be the
football game anymore but what the
first game and we have I have
v  said that i wasn't a plane playmaker at first
but very much
after lying played an ice hockey
game then we played a formula
1 game and then we
said watch out after two years i
have to go to germany i have to play
football and then  playing soccer games was
okay again like
my buddy's ok we're
best friends today the ok played a good
soccer game and then played a
lot of other games more and more
which then always means something here I can choose
from the nearby sports games
own ice own passion but in the
end the big players were also games
for the masses are real games
that have nothing to do with football and
real
athletes, so to speak
but it doesn't matter because people first understand each other in
their own fantasy world
a gamer wil  l would like to
forget everyday life and would like to
flee into a fantasy world exactly what is
on offer with our games and
the licenses have that for themselves about
what he about the aareal the biggest big
point game so I think that was
probably the most commercially
successful farmerama that a
color game  this game also came about more by a really
really coincidence,
but it was a game and
you could control the virtual farm
and
yes, it also followed quite a story how
we came to be a student who
had just done an internship with us
and a programmer who we just were
n’t one hundred percent
but ok then you also work
weird farm idea no one
really observed
them they come so act completely freely and
only three four months later
they came out with the game we will
launch it and with an explosion in
user numbers I think we will  are there per
per day later so around the  100,000 new
players per day have grown so
really put a top on it that
was it then but also on the
house at the beginning certainly a
bit but most of it then
really a lot a lot advertising we
did a lot with prosieben for
example both prosieben too  a
nice anecdote back in the early days
the first tv campaign was
tried out and i still remember how i
told the hat we now make
computer games that you can play in the
browser and then this selling item is
such a single business model behind it
and but look  one of them
believed us said let's try it out
and we'll give you a bit we
have time on webnews abba so media for
rapidshare more because but that
was the deal well and then the
first band came back then maybe 30
people did it  and have or at 6
p.m. something between the simpsons at
prosieben then ran under very first
sport j  a of course all the companies of the five
wise men together from the tv and want to see
this first the big highlight
of the company and then it came and
i had to take care of it beforehand
that the servers run and what
happens the board runs twice later
all servers crashed like that  a lot of
people registered there all of a sudden and they were
already panicking oh my god yes the
very next day I'm sure to call me to try
it you're the biggest politicians
don't talk to you
anymore they can't do it
quite the opposite the greeks
really on am  next day and were
totally thrown congratulated me
and never thought that their media
would have so much power that they
could crash on our servers and then only
asked that both the next
spots be broadcast you buy several
servers and offer more servers what's that supposed to
mean  already a very, very early tv
advertising time prince for digital
promise 2005 about the za  hl
even before even going to land yes yes
that was exactly it was it was
so worthwhile for you afterwards i
think he thought that the word reveal that
you were partially lucrative to
use us as
to market the
remaining space to the expedition and you the future  to squander it
then they advertised it to us because the
public was higher than a
correct one simply because it was so
particularly useful all of a sudden that
it was advertised on tv for a game
where they just had to type in the
url and it could start
playing immediately  back then it was still free
only paying on a voluntary basis that
worked extremely well
bigpoint peak times how many
people migrate so we tell you will be
active exactly almost 1000 so if user
or that user so i left in
2011/12 we were over 300  millions of
registered users
and i would say pixar concurrent
users and he picks the newspaper for the
millions of the same ones
in the same second we went
to the world of goods and then
actively involved and had 30 languages and we ha
office is all over the world so co
pletely in the sales service marke
ing officer is it then reall
to be able to adapt the l
cally  to be able to play and advertise
that was also the first or one of the
first really big german gaming
companies so gameforge austrian
early and 12 more but further a
lot of legs were heavy i think
one of the first really big commercial companies that
were successful later there were more  good games
or innogames hamburg hamburg was
a bit over that
we actually had gaming in germany, for example,
very successful in this area because
germans play these strategy games
german were still
not so focused on having the
best graphics or the best  animations
have to be but a lot goes over
your head and you  These strategy games that we had
all developed were
very top-heavy and not visually very
plastic and that works well in the
German market and with the income
that we had in the German
market we were then able to develop games
that work well in other markets
and that's why  Germany was just a
strong tree of hamburg maybe he
would want to write a little something to the hamburger
sponsorship gamecity hamburg
who worked
hard to settle german games companies in
hamburg i got to know
my first love so the
direct brothers clearly have where
not  sometimes when you know each other, of course,
but the idea is yes, but
maybe you can buy earlier so what for
years he is even when you
started you have your ex
employee of ours who just became
self-employed and you bought it
because he unfortunately you have
Never asked me but if you are honest
is in the at the time i
didn’t always make the best
decisions either that eminem was another
nice story is oliver samba was
then met then again was
at bigpoint is investing and one day i
said hello i
have an entrepreneur  met in berlin he
makes such a
games platform games company for
facebook that was still the same he said the number of
facebook and look at that
facebook and games how is that supposed to
work what a stupid idea
I had on team back then
and did you see  look at that i
want to give the founder a call well
the company was then even the you
want to have made one of the big players
poorer yes ten billion
went on the stock exchange and the deal he
offered me at the time likes pink so that
was him  zynga founder said
the christen rapidshare if you give us
your games and healthy share in
the company so the ante  ile while was
worth more than bigpoint was ever
worth such a stupid decision by
facebook and games doesn't work
because that's an anecdote cannstatt
for example i now have a lot at
gruner and year and there also in
assisi and then a few more months when they're
there  investment unit and then have the
strength first of all it's old at the time it's
the result we wished it
could have been
involved and we then I think we
also had a group order that was
canceled afterwards so figures would probably
also be a good thing to choose there
it didn't but it started back then and i
'm going back from files so that the
boy for a heinemann then sat with you
because of the participation at the time and then
in the calculated the accounts of
playing and started
to polemicize this game a little courtly that
it's very cool that's why he knows he's
not coming anymore
they sat together with christian vollmann in my room
order from oli samba never sat in
my office have so health resort now
sorted like that what a cost calculation
yes no idea at all break the
cohorts discounted it and
does it still make sense to continue with it
will be an offer from
nbc universal dem
to be bought by a big hollywood studio and oliver i know
then let's take a look so it wasn't worth it
apparently but flo and
christian must have told him it's
worth it because he made me an offer but it was
an immoral offer and the team
turned it down and then he then
so another
salesman got out and that was a
bit convincing.
i stuck with them because i have a
lot of young people
dreaming of having companies in games and
making their own games and that
was kind of cool yeah someone like that  count
I make games yes that's cool but the
word has kept I probably would have
h bigpoint was also able to carry on with
my life a little bit
because it gave me so much
pleasure because you
just no longer gave yourself the constellation
and continued so investors should
I can but want something new in there
until june versailles so that they  big
hollywood young star 1 and that was for
me where i thought cool that's
the way to the really big licenses
now you can make really great games
there was hardly ever
something to do in the valley and exactly the
ban to ignore that  then
everything that he said came about okay now
let’s attack the usa and
then i really went
over to san francisco with a small team from then
there office opened up for bigpoint
century you hired and
started developing games we got big
licenses like  battlestar
galactica ice age the mummy and later
even game of thrones yes that was then it
's awesome that's the whole thing now
kiss floppy that was the fashion
piquantly 1000 people worldwide
lessons i know then in terms of sales
what was that for the
pensions about 150 million sales our
for 30 million profit a year
probably would have company and
double every year there were no really
big Wessis trainers  I mean of course
anyone who was together more often got in first
but not now you can see
that today in 30 percent of the cases you
don't know at all so my
very first one like her was even
smaller than her there what you put in the
first million as if  I got
on is not mentioned
internet got on with an Asian woman
already a few people here too a
nice story
aggressiveness oliver got me on in the
summer and says now we're going full
throttle well now I have to get all my
jamba contacts and we're pushing you at mtv
viva back then  the big music stations
each advertising island brings your games in
have a  we really did it and all
the money we got from
him we really pumped rhein and
i called something but no more money
yes i don’t care about that
keep going we’ll figure it out and so on
don’t worry about money
okay but then  but also came
around the corner with united internet here the
third one said he would also
invest that will come then okay
then we met and we invested
with you everything is cool and then i
remember exactly christmas party at that
i will no longer have any money  had gotten to do a
christmas party and it was
actually empty and he says it'll
work then that will work and the next
i should have the notary appointment we do
n't change the entrance and it was totally
clear when the christmas party was here and
tomorrow morning and i don't know how
streams  I can't take place
the next day. A notice is yes, but by way of the next day, United
Internet surfaced about it  he who also signed for
the notary appointment
he then also planned again in the no
money that wasn’t so that
we still owned 100 percent but
i always had a very
pleasant very fair partner with me
that was also known at the time as the vat
about the  was more than 100 million
today would have a little bit what
today would have
the concerts definitely because of the
numbers we present
we tripled the sales in the first year
after that what doubled really
amazing numbers and above all the
difference that we have to
many other games increasing we were
n't just a one-hit wonder we did
n't have a hit game we
just developed our own i think 506
hits were hits so games that i would say
have made at least 20 30 million annual sales over the
years  Bigpoint is still alive today before the
games I gave 15, 15, 16 years ago,
how do you think you can explain how it was
because you were in it
yourself or because that was your
protest i don't think the others
had so i think i so i
'm geist or big gameloft had a good
team who understood how to
play a game about and i think that's special
and that doesn't just apply to us
, then we play a lot of games, that's
why a community was built, this
community should stay with us for a very long time,
and the other thing is, once
you've invested in a game like this,
it makes sense for you to keep playing
because the users  sometimes
spend significant amounts on it and since
you've invested a few hundred euros in the game then you won't
get paid tomorrow of course just say up and something else is and somehow stays with it maybe not for a
few weeks or months and then
maybe a little bit
hit a small one again and that's what makes it
so exciting and the sales were
n't there, but there were no advertising marketers  s was
99.9 percent of everything we paid
for about days played out of their
role because you could buy players for a football game
and that's exactly how it was in
the end
angry tongues always said
it could have been
because ultimately you  you
get the better sword or the
better vehicle the best
soccer player but
now we couldn't that was very
important that's called balancing in the
gaming area the balancing set in such a way
that even a non-
paying customer could also achieve
that but i have to have the time
say the 12 13 14
year olds who had a lot of time after
school could do it themselves again
the man who is maybe 40 years old
at work has an hour to play especially since he was
willing to spend five euros to go back the same
level  i remember that
i followed the story and
the feeling very likely for for
ff  back then one of the biggest deals about
will only be through one night we
probably have bigger consequences if from a
shower i was in hamburg
at least something like that and a true story
so i gave hinrichs with xing
and then there was you like this
Gaming madness so I thought that at
that time is the biggest
ever on the market actually
if you if you are a trainer you will
probably also somewhere with
more if you look back at the weather the
same way if you are a trainer
then you can’t really  with of
course i noticed that
somehow there were a lot of media inquiries
that people talked about it
but basically i always thought i
didn’t have to worry about it every day
and fight behind it that
this sales also come to the point that the
next users come i don’t know
for  me okay that's all easy col and if
that how big the back then for the erv
I don't know but I gl  aube oliver was
very satisfied
among many other
things one
really has to respect the colleagues from vodafone for how
many ideas they always come up with
to make their business customers happy the
latest is called dieweiß lifecycle
management that means for four
euros 95 per month and phone number you can  as a
company as a company make sure
that all the smartphones in the
workforce are protected if
they ever break you
get a new one the next working day costs also
a flat rate that is quickly
repaired a smart
device management that means configuration
distribution that too  of the
devices only the vodafone for a
company for the entire workforce
for the entire smartphone fourth,
so to speak, if you want to know more, it's
best to google vodafone and the
wayss lifecycle management
and that's how the users came from back then, so
only now at the at the first companies
with the  ring tones there came the number from
print advertising in the bild newspaper
so there was even an offline to online
conversion program that had in the
browser games back then it was more
offline to phone number conversion rate
formans marketing and tv so tv was
already like I
said before a whole  important driver
that tv too if that was the driver
is that just one of the drivers
performance for a long time one of
the big google entertainment here
in germany and europe even so
millions have already carried it in
watched online games every month
that is right after  certain game with
the keywords what exactly was such a
nice number the keyword boredom was
an important keyword that we shopped for a long time
really long because he entered a
message on google
and then yes if you have a long time
then the
situation is the first comes well  yes, so
we've done the keyword since then and how did it go
for you, so to speak, or  he why are
you out well and then we did
for nbc universal the
topic we had is over but bought from kers
before that it was so big restructuring but i know
what should you do with the one
european game that
no longer suits us  and then
we sold to two projects the fans
so the ones sold i only sold a
minimal one then
sold it and there can 2p israel with
clear objectives as i
mentioned earlier is free and the stock exchange
linkedin facebook all the goods
are downright  went to the stock exchange and we
thought okay what we have that you the
german european hungarian and why
are we with the i bring to the stock exchange
so it was very clear they we wont buy each other
a week later there was gold with
six bands on the mat and
we did  talked about how we
can bring the thing to the stock market, the
annoying thing that happened at the
same time, for the very first time, was a
whole  company history at that time the
company was already ten years old,
suddenly the sales were flat, yes, we have
not grown any more, each
month clearly at least 100 200,000
euros more sales than in the month before and
suddenly that does not happen facebook yes
certainly exactly because because facebook
games mobile gaming  was suddenly a
very big topic we weren't just
historically on it so talk to
external switch to which we didn't
react well enough
and then it quickly became clear the IPO
doesn't make any sense the numbers are
n't strong enough to get a good rating
and  then it was okay we're going
to restructure the whole company
and then i said to myself okay i
understand what you want to do there is
also a strategy i don't think it's
right i'll implement this
restructuring for you now and i can't leave
it alone nine cdu
not looking for work an everything is fine
but that is not my company and have
there  here decided okay I'll do it for
you now for a half three quarters
and then I'll go out of course
went out as
operational ceo and I said immediately
so it was clear what should I have
so many people were thousands who
were there at the time I have it myself
that many will then try to
influence me if the new ceo is still
there and come and
speak to him and then immediately went on a
world tour for a year
really left hamburg germany
so that i didn't have too soon and
it was me  Personally, it's just not
bad, unfortunately, it
also holds, yes, I just
held it
for one, further convinced
that he's doing the right thing, that just has to be the
next hit, or the transit
transit added to the mobile, it just has to
work, then it's all right
normal further but the way
the way was not the way she didn't want to
go and but some way  dwas under pressure to
sell
well the pi was
also dropped but ok or buy it
now to a chinese game
company called susie or where the
tradition has started again and
that was a
few years later that was yes
remember two years later okay you will
come back from the world and then
you decided now
i know gaming but the new one had almost come back from the world
trip and then
i spent the best summer of my life in mallorca in my opinion a
few  buddies de mallorca ibiza commuted back
and forth but had a great time
and if you hardly doubt the whole
thing that he's really cool but
she also has to earn money we have
to go back and do we can do normal
jobs not only
hang out here with her and then  suddenly
alone so September
as the thermal bath 2013 and there is no heat
what are you doing now
bored yes then f  i'm now
back in hamburg and basically like a
company in
hamburg ok what can you do that
you can me gaming again can you
and have built up the entrances company
a completely different genre but also with
the clear celebratory meeting okay the
company built up from the very
bergische  element around these are sold a few
years later that was heard was
games exactly that was games and
the basic idea of games or the thesi
was that 20 21 the gambling market in ge
many would be liberalized and onlin
gambling is not n
t not allowed in germany yes it  there are
two possible applicants pool competitions
who do something but usually
know that schleswig-holstein
licensed goods now also
commits in detail to explain that
the basic issue was for us to say
we are building a legal casino and that
was that they say you can play all the games
black jack roulette
slot machines in our casino but
you cannot win any money  n you're
just playing for fun and you'll say okay but
why should I do this and
also have to pay money for it so if
you want to bet that's the
chance at roulette with us you
still have to buy this chance and like that
works for us in that we
said and realized that the
psychology for a user who was behind is
only when i have actually put in
money no matter how little that is
then i have a real
thrill and people want to have the
thrill so you have to be able to
you buy a million
chance for one euro and you can even play with us for days,
weeks, months
and it worked so well
that we have won a good mid
double-digit million number of users
in German or in German-speaking
countries for our product
I will somehow get paid sometime
then you can gamble so you can always have
the chance of course to buy it
now  Not that everyone only gave
out, but also spent significantly
more, but we have
built up companies so that the
large user database in the
German-speaking area has for people
who are interested in gambling
roulette blackjack even though they
haven't gambled in it for years
exactly, although they actually only
played like that, but of course they always
did surveys and then asked with a
clear objective to say 20
21 individualization comes then
we also want to sell the company to those
who then
want to offer real gambling that
was always the  clear objective back then
okay that’s also how you then
explained jörg hellwig i financed it
myself with a couple of angels
you would say those who were friends of
the industry were there
yes but it wasn’t a big sum i raised
a total of one million
euros that
be a pro with the ball  tabel so it's the one who
bought always likes to ask for sales figures
so while you've made the
company for 50 million in sales and
ten million wow but still
rhymes against the only one with the
same business model we've never been
lucky and offers to this day  the
company also does not gamble
or causes it is not a
gamble in any way that it was only always the
idea for the excel we have now
sold but the goal
was implemented right at the top and
now what he wrote has come and
not even that though  we fouled
and the objective sold exactly at
the time that is the
name of the company it's called syrien is
a dutch game company that
pretty much reflects a lot of eyes just bought and sort of consolidated under an umbrella brand
if that sounds
so simple now from the model  because somehow
the well-known games of chance offer
entry and ask for it  nd then you can
play the game people could play
and you pay you were so sometimes you can
win money it didn't matter
so in the legal harmless version
it sounds like we were almost as
good but can build a business that
the core is based on that  Coming is of course
I didn't tell everyone I would have
gone to the casino because by the way you have to use money just like in a
real casino and that has
all the bad luck you'll do if you ca
n't win any money of course a bird
showed it won that
someone should do it that's crazy  yes
that still works that has my
first stand and understands the psychology behind it
and beer i have already mentioned
the word for petrol if you
understand how to build you will that the
user still has enough thrills for the use of money
gets
the said hey that  brings me fun and
I have the right excitement in the
evenings when I gamble a bit and
that I get up different  ok because i go
to the arcade or the casino or
somewhere else but you were
n't the gaming designer
or the content creator then you were
the type who
understood marketing again exactly whether marketing
i think i understand like users  or
why users are willing to spend money on a
product i have
i'm particularly good at that and that's what i'm
about the game designers the creative people
who make sure that the fun
is there you give them to marketing people who
try stop users clasmann why
should they join  register and
participate and i understand how to dose the number okay
why we ask for what money where at which point
in the difficult
casino or in every game that
we have to ask for money from someone at that moment
probably actually had a negative
experience but because  you gambled away all your
money speaking at the beginning
i have to say hey buy
like kri  Do you like that or the same for
every other game if you had sword fighting
it or whatever played a lot of games
you just lost
and now i want you buy and
better gear or is it hard
then win next time
so this one too  to catch moments exactly
and to know which price point
i can now from the user extension
is also willing to spend money okay
okay that's now in the end
a lot of social engineering is
social mechanics recognize and you
psychology that to know the user correctly
if  your psychology
rather than finding out with data models and
statistical twins etc.
why did someone
pay for goods in the same situation why can
you pay again now and how
big would it be from the
people have 80 people that's just
my intention i didn't want to  what
big have yes so 480 has
calculated and then you can the
offer to me jet  zt then, so to speak,
coincidentally actually in the year 21
where the
state treaty on gambling is now being changed
but for other reasons you
can just sell the deal that the deal offered itself
exactly we had talked quite well with
super chic gambling companies
there were once the companies want to
sell but yes then  the company came to
the corner and made a
better offer that's the
way it is at roadshows and you have the level that
he shows as a crooner so were you still there
i was at the roadshow
viasuisse with the ml ready from new york
with the worldwide with various stations
company has spoken and i
have a team
i left the company a year and a half ago
because i didn’t
want it if you buy us that i
’m the one who’s still tied up like a two three
years so we have a
top  team from my expect online
selected the boxes to
suffer with the lead and they have
egg  actually made the main sale
and the thank you thank you and then maybe
just because we are now asking the marketing
question because
interestingly enough it first of all
benefits a lot from television advertising performance marketing
that was
very fresh back then so as the first with
bigpoint what was the channel construction games  the
players got that too you have performance
marketing but also in mobile
marketing clearly the good thing is that we were
n’t gambling we could
also use all channels we
were locked up somewhere because it’s
just a game it’s just the
mechanics or  the setting one is of
a casino just used
so performance brand is always
what we didn’t primarily rely on
we thought twice about
doing branding and
also ran my branding campaigns tv
the domain jackpot it.de
so actually very much  memorably appropriate
for this have found that we
drive much better with performance campaigns and we'll bring
that back quickly ok and
just like that means really made it right in
mobile networks and otherwise like
many mobile networks in the 4 mobile gaming
networks then in there almost to
address the target group of gamers too  that
's really the case that the
bremen still deliver it in a sensible way like quality
hey you probably buy
compared to other e-commerce
models of purchase of course the large
number of users so you
usually pay relatively little if it if you well
that  are good german that is
now more but if you are good have
a time under 1 euro for such a
new installer for new registrations
for a user and there is the question
how christian are users now converted to a
paying customer and how
kristin that he  then stays with you for a long time
so look at the so-called day
one to 37 retention so how often
does he lure himself in and then the question is
how quickly can you convert
users to paying customers in these first seven days
, so you can see
relatively quickly whether they can be formed on
which channel strong health resorts that duh
can monetize in the long term
yes ok ok  that
means the thing is also through testing
through touching through touching all networks
all somehow
providers for mobile advertising that
somehow there is always money
coming in correctly exactly yes and then when
you have found something then of course then
full throttle so to speak again the
marketing and sales  I did mr.
ecommerce what I really
works there but yes so clearly as far as
you found the channel then there is
only that is super super numbers
driven so little
to do with creativity but really just
watch okay
which which which which stylistic device
works on which channel  on
which target group how well that means
not there  ss a channel works completely or not at all
on a channel you
can only buy weaker users
the old
ones have lower value so you have no idea you
now also have that is quite a
long time honestly
I noticed again so if you  games
you then keep growing new players
that love i rather am totally
enthusiastic unfortunately yes that is
really bad the business angel yes because
someone comes along tells jan fitschen the
idea and so before come on do it until
i understand that my money is
finite  not like a company
was always new - had money
coming in i always have one time,
by the way, when i sold
something i have a different topic
and said okay i hardly invest in
direct start-ups
myself anymore and then i have a few fans
invested directly and I
'm still in the industry, so to
speak, so any money is still produced, of course  en
we have a few good ones mid mid mid mid
but
i don't have a unicorn unfortunately with with
financially but i probably also
with it again before from i am a good
33 one and a half years ago i got out a big
angel number i hardly
ever decide before that you
so feeling i would have felt for years since
the corresponding start-up scene german
startups portals did you do it there
with 30 40 50 pieces more that
stays my whole life has done at over
100 like today maybe
have
50-60 in which i  I'm still active in it
, then there are those who run better
and maybe at some point
I don't have money, unfortunately,
I didn't
keep it  to
hear that even someone who comes from the
industry who is now
successful because he himself earns a lot of
money and then  angeles that makes you
think okay of course it's a slide
but no because you make
somehow 50 60 or even more
investments and it also really shows the
error image of the market a lot of things
just don't work completely
somehow to go through the roof and stuff like that
some things are going okay but you
have a huge miss quote and
that is often actually
distorted in portugal maybe know knowing if
you think of course I'm doing something and then
unicorn but that's just
not exactly recognizable at all absolutely so
I think  i would have done better and
better had i put my amazon shares i
think i would have made more
money than i once
did single investments nevertheless i gladly did it
and again this
industry in danger because it's just really
cool to be part of this
scene and to live like  what emerges from
nothing and
can become a big success a story that I
've noticed we can cure  z he must is
in the gaming time and hollywood
is that the described here has to have the
conscience with you there you are
also advertiser party crazy and
had to go through a bit of a
hard time there yes you have to get good talent
there has to somehow
create attention  but just really crazy
crazy parties celebrated legendary parties
one of the crazy
things was definitely for example the
playboy mansion we rented
it really the official playboy
mansion by hugh hefner who was exactly
right yes but unfortunately not there himself
we asked ex  but could also
come but he didn't come
but all the playboy bunnies ran riot
and accordingly lightly dressed yes
that the gamers love that of course there was a
huge turn on it the ticket are
enthusiastic i had never received so many
contact requests that somehow contacted
me  have wanted to go this batch
because it is supposed to burn in the fire
was it the itri that's the
big gaming fair in los angeles and
so within the framework of this fair how
do we throw the party there
and that of course then the playboy
mansion and everyone at the e3 in los
angeles wanted to get to know hubert and
caught up on this game so that was and
that should also be in the white tigers was
also that you had a different story and
another thing was crazy thing i
went all the way to san francisco to build up
herbal from there and a few
buddies say then that is so cool that
you're here and it's your birthday
we probably don't want to come visit say
come celebrate with your birthday
how cool that's awesome of you of course
but I have the gold curfew so
say at one or two don't
remember exactly it's closing time that's
totally [ __ ]  if you we do that in
las vegas and then we meet because of
that comes or to las vegas it
doesn't matter well well ok come we want to do it
suddenly more and more people and
suddenly it's so gentle people are flying in from
germany and
celebrating my birthday like a special
birthday is the only way to celebrate a birthday
we have something special i
'm 40 years old well and he's okay
then a bit  come up with something new and
the mean employee and a
waning one doesn't like that
flown out
us there's such an
event organizer tailor-made okay here
comes German crazy we want to
celebrate the awesome party and you know
from the film hangover or what I
always want to do let's try hangover again
so celebrating is how we after yes i will
make everything clear for you and then
yes and one of the stories afterwards
what happened one of my
best buddies had
my name tattooed on his on the
upper part another got married
spontaneously so really  landed the portal and picked it up
at the
airport  rat and
his girlfriend antje with that
we both do that so i organized another
wedding within four days
and he bought him the dress
when then they got married
there and the other thing was that they then
bite tigers so that was all
after the big accident  at that time we
found another artist who
walked through the hotel lobby with his two tigers on metal
chains and into the
elevator if you wrong up
to our suite where we celebrated the party
and then he went
into the street with the two tigers so there was
no cage  can't do anything is then in
there and then made a bit of a
show for us and how
high you were allowed to be without
touching will be brave enough was unfortunately
some already drunk beutin tiger
riding so can't be passed ten
best ball is that germany  again
about exactly a few employees then
also there
so the legendary one for the animals 100
million  take out insurance because
that can't be in the cage must how important
a lobby so i was upstairs the whole
time unfortunately i didn't see them i was happy to see
they were harmless so the
insurance was maybe 1000 dollars
and the artist with then two tigers
maybe has the three  got 4000 dollars
or so for his legendary number so
yes we had a really really
awesome party then it was a really
awesome gaming site that was really the
epic games yes yes absolutely there yes
actually like what is because the gaming
are still there today  so that's how it is when
you hear it so performance marketing
oriented then
you don't expect it at all yes well yes partly yes
there are only providers who
also celebrate wild parties and now
really celebrate if they have a new
hit but that's okay  Of course it's
much more brutal and more competitive than it was in
my day, to be honest,
it was a very close one  A
scene that understood exactly how you
could earn money today through
mobile gaming and the infinitely
large number of apps and the incredibly
large number of other digital
entertainment options has made the
gaming scene significantly
more difficult, but like you it’s fine, but
that’s why I think  that we are
still consulting about until so
labs made and hope
there are a few companies listed on the swedish
stock exchange like still von
embrace who do exactly that so
consume a lot buy a lot and
bring together for the first time total are users of game too  to
get the game to do just that power power power
really send that you
can keep your marketing cost-effective because he
says the help and says there are
no that's the games colleagues who
also earned a lot of money with it and
I think the three percent of
rock'n'roll something quite clear that
they had what they delivered  n so
you free beckmann the two gaming
it then somehow a good
breeding ground for cras under which in the end yes
yes i think that the special
thing is that you don't have a problem with gaming
you have to multi product and
make them right away on an international
level  and you are a hit-
driven business that's just not
in wiesau yes i have your
products now it just runs through
that just optimize you have to
optimize your products must always be up to
date latest technologies latest telephones latest java poland
etc. always  have to re-enter
so that you're still relevant somewhere
in the in the in the target group ok and
now a new thing, so to speak, so it
wasn't that long ago that
you gave it out so it's nice but
it wasn't that long ago that it was
clever  So can I
get everything out afterwards, have you taken a break here again, a
little more
Yorker or I don't have a break either
done i continued right away because
i was already at im
flow so i founded a new company here
whether solo means that and the
special for the first time
made here that i got a crest for the
first time and
got it in so  i said all the
other topics i used to do on my
own i also love to be honest
i like to be the one m driver's
these seats and make the decisions
but here with me it's okay okay i would like
to make
decisions together with someone see she is
leading for me is  feels
very good so far what are we doing there i
always say the big one like new year's eve without
elisabetta was a soloist has also had various
start-up experiences but was
actually much longer outside of
the scene a bit a bit of
fans on the road has a small
start-  ups euro helped out met us
through a mutual acquaintance who i
told him i s  I am looking for someone to be a co-
founder and I would like to emphasize
that I really wanted to
have a woman’s perspective on the whole
business life on my decision
and I said yes, I know
my girlfriend and so on
like ass all of a sudden
fit and ok then
keep looking we'll try it now
just try it we've been
together for almost a year
what are we trying the really big
vision all star trek fans now know
what i'm talking about is to recreate the
holodeck  yes, that really big
vision what do we need we have developed
various arts intelligence
modules are able to have people represented
by an ai or
characters represented so
it can be presented we can be able to
with a little video material i
need 30 minutes  video footage of the
person i need a bit more
votes than real samsung for three
st  And then still material and then all the
content about the person that I can find
and can simulate that person completely
then you can talk to the
press and that's just that
capable of being the term that many
will belong to or know and then
it feels like  anyway a zoom
kreuth can suddenly do with albert
einstein yeah that's sort of like they know
the idea behind it that all the first
product that we're going to launch now
that means tips for a children's product
in which the children
can talk to theirs in harry potter
batman superman or or or
whoever and not only that i can talk to her
but
come play games together you can
read better and they come together
to learn something the decisive thing is that
beautiful examples bring more
if the child would not tell haye
was  a holiday to
france with mum and dad then mastercard will also
ask hey what you actually what they
the capital is in france or knows
what thank you means in french yes that's how
the child speaks in dialogue with
harry potter would suddenly learn things that
you could only convey to us so dry and boring
and that's one of
the first models and that's
completely through an KI  don't get in the
way of scripts like this here it's
complete we're working on it all the time and it's all
back to normal that's why there's
already a model to address my part 10
euros so that you can access all the characters
and then the child
can work with them and then it's okay
additional content there comes
out a playful topic again wilson
further so can't play another game
or can read more books with the child
or that the character was
missing but had special glasses
has how special it
can be designed is its intended for mobile phones is
exactly that  the very first we'll start with
the app then we'll go to the next
level  be in augmented reality that you can place
this character in the living room in
a children's playroom
and so on and so on that
means that it sounds like the vision
that you already have something 1 34 15
exactly, but
we're going to do it now  first of all heir in the thin
and the character she is on the cell phone
he moves there talks to you
talk to you and learns with her game
of games etc should be the best
friend that especially those who build there
know is a more user knowledge
grip  that means that we
really save everything the child says
and process it for the future if
the child tells me i got a
dog today then we will know
in three four five weeks that there is a dog
we can still ask hey what
about that dog  and then it's time to
go for a walk or then come back and
build those and funny tricks
etc. so we try to do something for the
children  offer an experience that you
didn't know before he as
entertainment how did you
come up with it when I can
understand where
it came from with the other games and what probably
triggered moments in her
wanting to found something like this right down to the
pairing  so 20 21 this right there
must prepare us what to how
can that now so what was there the
initial connection via so the
story must be a little bit abroad
skillful sad how
the original idea actually came about
and although my father had very serious
cancer it was very  sure will
die and the idea i was just about
to have a daughter and the idea
was actually to say hey how cool
would it be if my daughter could
still talk to my dad for sure
even though she will never really get to
know and if i made a few
videos  just record and just
interview and free just so easy to
tell from his life  n and
i build ne qaidas on top of that i
can talk to my bike i
then told my mother and a few friends
and my sister and alb
gets everything bookeen that is that
we don't think it's good and so on we did
a bit of market research  with
the pin jude by the way expected the
team then comes but would also like it
differently had nobody went so well
other than putin don't want that
then i just kicked it around
okay how cool would it be if my
daughter got along with somewhere
could entertain in a different way and then I just saw
role models like that there is another one
called talking tom and
looked at a lot of other things what these children
areas children area big is
successful and then
found out ok that worked
did a bit of
market research and noticed ok children would be
interested  chatting
, interacting and
exchanging with virtual cards etc  and say if you do what
exactly then the ki so in the case
of my father if that had done
what would have anticipated your promises the
answers and then
say yes given deputy your
father is exactly right so
ultimately you train that in the
case  that talking about that now would
be half in the model, so a natural
language processing the model
you train with sometimes a lot of
content that you can somehow
make available is under this
list of questions and then behind it you have 1000
of answers that he then stops for the ducati
inside you will be asked a lot with your
father
where you come from where it was a
childhood love story and so
water and then it would all have been
saved like this
ddp which then spit out according to his daughter's questions
or the
assigned questions and  that's
even brought together accordingly and out of
context to take possession of  okay if
she asks that, this or that
topic could go well with it, but
not that it's just just
answering questions given exactly the
answer he had given, but
really training a model
that can also answer holistically,
the work doesn't speak  only with the
data that you have of the respective object
let me say has the character hate
the case my father but leads
that together with other similar
models yes what maybe happened to the
year if told yes i was born in
the year then must  yes all the
information yes it still happens that
you can tell yes i was born in the
year in which german football became
world champion or something like that as an
example that was never said you
added that with it so that more good
story context simply is that the one
example that  different we build is then
just so guaranteed text-to-speech
so the whole boys makes the art
intelligence afterwards we  il we use
words if he said the word
football world cup
then we still have to be able to
speak it so we need his
whole voice to speak and the other thing is a
computer vision where we see everything that is there visually
of him because he himself is
lipping again  synchronicity when he said the word like
the soccer world teams
said then we don't know how his
lips would have moved exactly there but
because of the novel nets that we
then trained for it no matter what
letter which
loud sequence corresponding to the
lips move or if  we have to
recognize the emotions it's a dream
story and a funny story
talk to the man differently of course
the eyes bother you for a moment they
bother had all such stories
then comes through the computer
vision topic and that's just
not done for deceased people
but now, above all,
lead the los between channel sc  nice
things exactly so
dare to say it somehow that
somehow because not also famous
people you can invite them to watch football
and tell
anecdotes
loudly ki with you then exploded roots
correctly yes or take netflix and
just shot around the netflix  series and get
exactly the same characters from the
pixar are now sitting pleading on the on
his couch or maybe a first
date just in a cell phone and inside and
you watch the film with the group
and then they suddenly tell
anecdotes because we can hear it
carefully  what point is the series
of the team are you right now and
then suddenly the character comes and says what
follows that was the scene we shot
or watch out right now it's funny
how
what could that's really awesome like
you that's what we're doing in  compared to the
beginning was says okay here games are
also great visionary they have
monetarisie a bit faster  ren that
was all
felt tangible you knew what he
needed for the money that's
somehow you build a world or
you give it back to the us model
there is no dismantling of that kind
but we're trying very hard  products
have very close to the money - you just mentioned
works the first children's
product would have been
called talking tom before drying tom is
an app from the economy a cat
that only reproduces exactly what i
just said just hyped up
agree that's annoying ii  has several hundred
million active users per month so
that's it there are already similar
products and examples that prove that
it works so I've
seen it here in the research there is
somehow the first tv is called the first
product that's the children's product
taken okay okay okay
understood a topic what you there I know
again is you look what I have
n't even asked is
ma loses  g i didn't do much because
i
have a special feeling for the game even though i did a lot a lot
also such a nice story the
first things with which he
even earned money at beckmann but the first
games didn't bring in so much
money and for example quite a lot
domains bought all domains
tld expired at some point but were
automatically registered and did
n't have anything anymore there's an ebay link on it
blasted with some stuff and
was for a while ebase was the biggest
fulfilled your partner only if you
just started
with
[music]
and that's why
today you can no longer
imagine what the wild west was like back then
but mine is actually
worse isn't okay you get
a domain people given that he
goes directly and go to the site there is
nothing but the ebay link then
you click on it and buy  at that time ebay was
you after pension entitlements because one
of dirk waasen user fed too much
te from data domain and if you do it
on a large scale and have many
domains then you get something at five
euros more for your users and
that was good money for us at the time
we really made a lot of money and used
it to finance the first games but
that  for example, it's good that
we're picking it up again because
it's easy
to imagine today that you
can sort things out so easily you can
perhaps say more clearly influenza that
the post office still have a little how much money for
it but they have to
deal with it themselves for a while  Yes, a lot of work
with buying domains, but sometimes
I buy completely automatically and
looked exactly, simply looked at which
SIM card had become free. At that time, it was
still he who believes this page index page,
the number was what I do, yes,
you don't know exactly and
would have  at that time she gave the number how well
visible is a domain google if the
well visible or homepage i
had there you have it easy  remedial class exactly
and even people registered and then
automatically no one we want that
can be broken laughed is that we made
money with it invited by ebay to
berlin great courted
there and makes relaxed
ridiculous we all have a topic which one yes but
honestly from my colleagues
was written down or two
maybe one is somehow there was
a video from your association
he was somehow the social gaming what
you also means that somehow very
busy that was the area
will be a video of course and
you have a feeling for it  when i first saw
a big yellow man away so
i think there are always two sides of the
whole coin i think that one
is when you talk about children and they
play some games
then the parents also have a certain
duty of supervision we have to  see what works
, what doesn't work, the others are
the operators, who  Is it
responsible Who do we want to charge up to what
amount and
we have always tried to
block it in good time that a conscious
he you know that you have
spent no idea 200 euros this month
do you really want it and are you
really okay with that if  you use accounts
wanted to be blocked or that you
no longer wanted to be paid or
concerts payment
should be switched off then we just did everything
immediately if the if your
parents complained now
i think many sides have a
certain responsibility and  we have
always tried to fulfill our responsibilities as
well as we can now,
so i can understand that, but
how funny and really upset he was
. on the one hand i
didn't feel addressed by it and
then a few months ago magnus  you here
quite well well exactly a nice
story so for all d  ie the
resemblance
of a large touchscreen to a beautiful story one of my
employees was in malta at
an event and flew back and
suddenly the guy was sitting next to him
and yes and they were both chatting and
because that was great and that’s exactly what
good business we did together  then
our our quasi casinos
played with it in
his streams and yes, one of the employees
took care of it, that decisions were
made so well that knox didn’t poach
and until today knox
manager is there or david,
I think that’s just good  so
for me it's about how today made
self-employed then she has
to give her back and we do different things
and I think that's great
I always think it's terrible when
employees leave you and
go to another employer that means
I have something as an employer
not well done but when someone
leaves me for their own thing
then i'm always very
proud to say i've hired exactly the
right man and he's leaving
for exactly the right reasons
so i'm just great but also
because i got the question again at the time
with great who's applying
lucky  so he plays there too he
doesn't gamble you could in the
game we played together he
advertised indirectly on his platform or for a platform so to speak
you can't win anymore you can't win
any money and of course now you
've spent a lot of money again because
people like want to win even if no
money have the choice to win
that's why it's like a normal game yes
i'm willing
to spend a certain amount to have a certain
entertainment purpose just as i
'm willing like going to the cinema or when i go
to a festival or
somewhere else  then i'm willing
to spend this sum for my entertainment and
so that's one of them  zige what
you think then I think negative is
it just a casino game and not
a
no idea import car or something
but I know from you know
angeles spoken many
entrepreneurial projects
this investor so in the
capital markets also makes short say
for example yes  yes yes but i just ca
n't tell such great stories
so I discovered at some point in 2000
that it's so great although i have to say
it was already an employee back then i
had silver eyes we need a super
fit is so but had to provide many
servers and one of my employees
back then I was already told we can
surf bigpoint like
this it should
n’t take care of bitcoins
i understand i understand or classes the
gentleman had to be there quietly he has to
be there the business would probably have been
more lucrative the server used
bitcoins no but i
also like to do what i do  that's extremely
exciting
but I don't do that much from
re  ndi purposes even if that is certainly
to achieve a good return that as
he believes more that there is that
is a technology
that will be used in a variety of ways in the future
for a wide variety of things what is happening in the
mft area they are
totally exciting for gaming gaming  he
always asked the big question who owned
the item, the virtual sword belonged to
the game operator or the user who
bought it and he would solve exactly such
issues, yes, that would then belong to the
mrt and suddenly you would
create a secondary market where
users could sell their swords  then being
able to sell it to others again, it will be like that
as a game operator doesn’t have to
listen because that cannibalizes a
business model, but it
might be possible to bring in completely different new business
and then it’s very
exciting to see what’s happening there and
watch it and try so far
to take part of it, that is
, then receives a bit of equipment  so
i just have a bit and talk
to people from the scene and
now i'm finally trying to talk now the
security agree i do
n't have any big projects there that you don't buy any big projects there either
fts then also
no nfc yet but  what is not can still
we will now follow the oxo lohas
after solo history next have
references to the hamburger is yes at
yahoo mobile is but i have
not developed a complete remote fight
so from the beginning i have people
from all over the world  sitting the size
would have in europe heinz wants to the
european time zones if we work
together
but the people
you can find something here in
germany or in hamburg today and from the
consortium
we have all of india vietnam
greece save here in italy
got the  we build on it because
he already has very special topics like
the ones we do where we have very
precise sp  we
needed specs and have for that would
have sat on it so i think we have
we have almost 30 people now and i
think i hired 25 of the 30 through
resignations but the whole
thing finds itself well they find it
completely for themselves at the moment because it holds
really still very pocket
research is what we partly
do there and so far everyone who
invested money with me on where has invested in
me as long as I was on the lever
there never lost money that's what I want
here too so one day also a
stupid idea  which i'm following here right
now when i see that we're taking off
and that could be really successful
then i
would still want to take on financial investors in order to be able to
scale it but as long as we're
still developing a technology you
know what that means but you can
already do that in the  year it belonged to 30
people and so they have already inherited
a few million through millions
in the year yes
[Music]
I've already had a bit of
success from the company and
that's fun for me, so entrepreneurship also means that you're willing to take
risks and I'm
absolutely willing to take that because I'm totally
convinced of what we're building
here  forward-looking for
entertainment here okay everything is fine so
also for the great for hamburg so even
if it's not exactly like everyone
here but if the thing gets bigger here
the next thing was about a big
point I would be here for the city
I think depends  so as if
at least many years had given hamburg the
chance as a game city as
the gaming metropolis what else was there
karlsruher gameforge and hamburg was
just innogames bigpoint and well in
our league there was still
back then but you can have it
otherwise  today more in hamburg
a very big
many many thanks even if for the
accompaniment years i get along and
now meet s  ie from time to time there are
also supporters here so
five I'm very happy thank you very much
then everything was clear ciao ciao
for all those who have
personally decided to continue their education in 2022
I would have something and that's because
we finally have an area with
us  mr education and, among other things,
there are so-called deep dive courses there
and we deepen very much in depth on certain topics to
really get you further, e.g.
in the area of seo in the area of instagram marketing i
the area of digital analytix in the area of e-mail ma
keting you can learn a lot there
within a few
hours a lot of added value
for you and you also for your employer
who wants to do it intensively practical
either live and of course also digitally
and a personal part with a
certificate at the end you can take a
look at what you are offering and abyss
com is up to date  is there with the
voucher code there may 22 10 percent
on all courses so again  acquisition point may come stay
visit
[music]
this podcast is produced by
popstars
at mr